with the announcement of Luigi's Mansion
3 I was really curious where the
franchise was headed would Nintendo and
developer next-level games continue down
the path set by dark moon would they
veer more towards the original or would
it be an entirely new experience Luigi's
Mansion 3 actually takes elements from
both the original and dark moon to
create a clever mix of both Luigi's
Mansion 3 is set in a single hotel just
like how the original game takes place
in a single mansion but every floor is
unique which is more similar to dark
moon for example there's a medieval
floor a production studio and a museum
in the third game no longer you pulled
out and back to the lab every time you
finish an objective like dark moon and
you can even go back to any floor
whenever you'd like
Luigi's Mansion 3 also introduces the
character of Poulter kitty who sometimes
steals your elevator buttons poulter
kitty jumps from room to room and even
multiple floors this encourages you to
go back to other floors and look at them
from different angles it's true that
Luigi's Mansion 3 doesn't have portrait
ghosts like the original instead opting
for a boss at the end of each floor sort
of like how dark moon had a boss at the
end of each area but the bosses in the
third game can sometimes feel closer to
the portrait goes from the original than
the bosses and dark moon let's take two
distinct boss fights in Luigi's Mansion
3 the maid ghost chamber up from floor 5
and the t-rex goes from floor 9 jane
brie is pretty simple just shoot a
suction shot at the briefcase and go
from there
it's very similar to some of the
portrait ghosts in the original where
the solution to the fight is something
small like opening a window curtain then
you just suck away but if you look at
something like the t-rex from floor 9
it's much more involved and similar to
dark moons boss fights in that fight you
have to suck up the eggs that fall
shooting one of the t-rex to munch on
while you then shoot another at its
exposed chest I don't want to spoil how
to beat the fight but some goo could
really come in handy
so in this case you get the best of both
worlds and since there are 15 floors and
2 basements you get a larger pool of
bosses than just a few from Dark Moon
meaning there's room for both
[Music]
aesthetically Luigi's Mansion 3 keeps
the same ghost designs from Darkmoon but
its atmosphere is closer to the original
there are some genuinely creepy moments
in Luigi's Mansion 3 like when King Boo
first shows up and when the t-rex in the
museum first wakes up
but there are some light-hearted moments
too like the Godzilla fight and
paranormal productions and DJ Fantasma
glory in the dance hall more of an
evolution than a combination Luigi's
Mansion 3 brings back the dark light
from Dark Moon except now it doesn't
have a cool-down period and can be used
indefinitely the game also adds some
additional Poltergust expansions first
there's the suction shot which sends a
plunger with a rope at an object which
you can then pull on to destroy things
then there's the slam in dark moon if
you tapped a once the Poltergust meter
was charged you'd suck the ghost in a
little harder and drain more health in
the third game you can still charge up a
meter but now you can slam the ghosts
you can even slam the repeatedly dealing
some massive damage after that there's
the burst which can help you out if
you're surrounded or if the ghost has a
defense item it's also Luigi's only way
to jump in this game lastly there's GUI
G GUI G is essentially a second Luigi
who can slide through gates and help
Luigi when just one person isn't enough
I also want to note that there is the
super suction ability but it's
underutilized and can only be done when
connected to specific electrical outlets
when it comes to catching booze Luigi's
Mansion 3 is very similar to Dark Moon
the boo hides somewhere in the room and
once you find it you have to hit it with
a dark light in dark moon the longer you
charged up the meter the more health you
take from the boo but in the third game
you utilize the slam power the only
other difference is that now in Luigi's
Mansion 3 you can use HD Rumble to
locate where the boo might be hiding the
original game had a completely different
system where the boos wouldn't latch on
to the vacuum nozzle and they can easily
jump from room to room sometimes forcing
you to go to the floor above or below
the act of searching a room to find a
boo and then something going off to let
you know your clothes originated from
the first Luigi's Mansion but otherwise
the system from that game is completely
gone
egad as a character was fairly different
between the first two games in dark moon
he became rather rude and arrogant and
he was not like that at all in the
original game where he was just this
weird and eccentric scientist this is
especially evident with his toad helpers
who he treated like garbage throughout
Dark Moon while still a little arrogant
and looking out for himself it
significantly toned down in Luigi's
Mansion 3 in fact egad doesn't nearly
have his big of a role in the story he
gets tricked into coming to this haunted
hotel just like Luigi and rather early
on you save him from a painting from
there he gives you the virtual boo which
is this game's equivalent of the Gameboy
horror and the dual scream he has a few
moments throughout the story like his
insistence on getting the super suction
piece at any cost but for the most part
he just adds new Poltergust
modifications like Luigi and gives you
hints and tips when you need them you
can actually turn off the in-game hints
and never ask him for help
unlike the first two games where you
frequently had to go back to his lab so
you more or less control how much you
want to see egad besides a few required
instances early on given that this is
his and Luigi's third major outing
together maybe they're just getting more
comfortable and familiar with each other
or maybe egad finally understands the
importance of Luigi in his life so
whether you're a fan of the original a
fan of Dark Moon or a fan of both
Luigi's Mansion 3 has a little something
for everybody how do you feel about the
mix of its predecessors in Luigi's
Mansion 3 let us know in the comments
below and thanks for watching
[Music]
yeah
[Music]